the crew of the mts-42 spacecraft is on
an incredible two-year Mission to Mars
leading the team is the determined and
capable Mission Commander Marina Barnett
alongside her are the skilled biologist
David Kim and the diligent medical
researcher Zoe Levinson with hearts full
of anticipation and a sense of adventure
they Bid Farewell to Earth and soar into
the vast unknown during the thrilling
Ascent from our planet's surface their
rocket Parts slowly separate but during
the process an unforeseen incident
shakes the crew's world to their
astonishment Barnett discovers the
presence of Michael Adams a launch
support engineer who unintentionally
snuck aboard their vessel and the crew
notices something strange in his hands a
special device which is necessary for
purifying the ship's air entangled
between two modules but before they can
do anything about it the parts separate
and the device Falls right in front of
their eyes making the crew scared for
their Journey with their life-sustaining
air purification system compromised the
crew is faced with an urgent predicament
they resort to employing emergency
lithium hydroxide canisters to remove
the toxic carbon dioxide from their
surrounding however these canisters were
never intended to endure the additional
strain and their limited capacity
threatens the crew's survival in a Race
Against Time Barnett makes a crucial
decision she instructs David to initiate
his algae experiment on board the ship
instead of waiting until they reached
the Martian Colony as originally planned
with limited resources and a sense of
desperation lingering in the air David
sets to work cultivating the precious
algae which might be able to create
oxygen using carbon dioxide every moment
counts as he carefully tends to the
delicate organisms striving to create an
environment where they can Thrive
despite his best efforts the unforgiving
conditions take their toll and only half
of the algae managed to survive
nevertheless this small victory offers a
glimmer of hope a sufficient oxygen
supply for an additional crew member the
unplanned Michael but their relief is
short lives as now the crew has to face
another problem since the algae is only
able to provide oxygen for one person
for now the remaining people will have
to figure out a way to clean the air for
themselves or they will all have to die
a slow painful death as the crew thinks
about this Barnett desperate for a
solution that could save all four lives
reaches out to Mission Control seeking
their expertise however the options
presented to them proved to be far from
ideal the only possibility involves an
untested and highly dangerous extra
vehicular activity Eva commonly known as
a spacewalk this daring maneuver would
require the crew to ascend the lengthy
tethers and retrieve liquid oxygen from
the spent upper stage rocket the risks
are deemed too great jeopardizing the
lives of the entire crew faced with this
Grim reality Barnett and David
reluctantly start contemplating the
unthinkable sacrificing Michael to
ensure the survival of the remaining
crew members however as the crew thinks
about this Zoe with her unwavering
determination implores them to exercise
patience she urges them to Grant Mission
Control 10 more days to devise an
alternative course of action so maybe
they will be able to survive without
having to take huge risks days turn into
nights and the tension within the
confined spacecraft grows unbearable the
weight of their impending fate presses
heavily upon their shoulders struggling
to reconcile with the impending
sacrifice David take a bold step defying
the established order he breaks Rank and
approaches Michael and angrily discusses
the horrible situation they face David
is suggesting that the only practical
solution would be to show Michael mercy
and Grant him a swift clean release
using a lethal injection something that
would prevent pain on his side and allow
the crew to Live While this is happening
Michael also contemplates sacrificing
himself to save everyone as he was never
supposed to BT there in the first place
but before anything drastic can happen
Zoe intervenes once again and makes
everyone calm down and suggests the use
of the other alternative the dangerous
spacewalk and as the one who suggested
it she nominates herself to take the
dangerous step outside so that she may
retrieve the oxygen that everyone needs
but as this is happening David unveils
another devastating blow the remaining
algae the sole source of oxygen has
succumbed to the inhospitable conditions
leaving only enough to sustain two
individuals confronted with the imminent
loss of two crew members David
recognizes the gravity of the situation
and makes a Resolute decision he agrees
to join Zoe on the perilous climb
knowing full well the inherent dangers
that await them with their resolve
firmly in place Barnett David and Zoe
face the daunting task that lies ahead
with one mission that might save all of
them or result in the deaths of everyone
on board United the crew of mts-42 now
stand ready to face their most
formidable challenge yet undeterred by
the immense risks Zoe and David brace
themselves for the daunting extra
vehicular activity that lies ahead with
their hearts filled with determination
they venture out into the vastness of
space their mission clear to secure the
much needed liquid oxygen that will
sustain two additional passengers in a
remarkable display of resourcefulness
Zoe and David's skillfully jury rig a
makeshift solution managing to fill two
cylinders with precious oxygen this
newfound hope Kindles a flicker of
optimism within their weary Hearts
however their Triumph is short-lived as
a cataclysmic event unfolds a
high-energy solar flare in the form of a
coronal mass ejection unleashes deadly
radiation upon the unforgiving expanse
of space the crew is forced to make a
heart-wrenching choice abandon one of
the oxygen cylinders in order to escape
the clutches of this deadly radiation
resolute in their determination Zoe and
David Retreat to the sanctuary of their
ship their hearts heavy with the weight
of their sacrifices however their bad
luck doesn't end there as before they
are able to make use of the oxygen a
critical equipment failure strikes
resulting in the loss of the sole
remaining oxygen cylinder desperation
sets in as they grapple with the
realization that their Lifeline is
slipping away leaving them teetering on
the precipice of Despair in this dire
moment a glimmer of hope emerges from
the otherwise desperate situation a
realization Dawns upon the crew while
they have list much of their Lifeline
the tank that they had lost earlier due
to the solar flare still isn't
completely lost and is still there
although it continues to leak precious
oxygen due to their improvised
connection and finally with that piece
of information the crew creates a final
desperate plan if one person is willing
to go outside to retrieve it they might
be able to provide the remaining people
with enough oxygen however there is one
caveat to retrieve the oxygen and for
the oxygen to be enough for everyone the
person will have to sacrifice themselves
by being exposed to the lethal radiation
outside as the entire crew contemplates
this they have to decide decide who must
take this step Marina as the
indispensable pilot of the ship must
endure to ensure the safe return of the
crew Michael untrained for such perilous
Endeavors and David with his family
waiting anxiously back home however
amidst the turmoil of emotions Zoe
stands unwavering steadfast in her
decision she firmly insists on
shouldering the burden herself driven by
an unyielding determination to save her
comrades with a heavy heart and
unwavering resolve Zoe steps into the
abyss embracing the lethal radiation
that awaits her she embarks on a
treacherous Mission driven by the
strength of her spirit and the
unwavering belief in the bonds that tie
their crew together the minutes tick by
fraught with tension and uncertainty
until finally Zoe emerges triumphant
clutching the retrieved cylinder that
holds their fragile hopes yet Victory
comes at a devastating cost the lethal
radiation has taken its toll on Zoe
leaving her body weakened and ravaged by
its Insidious grasp as she returns to
the confines of the ship her strength
wanes and the final remnants of Life
slip away in her last moments she gazes
out into the cosmic Abyss her gaze fixed
upon the distant Mars a faint glimmer
amidst the twinkling stars she leaves
this world knowing that her sacrifice
has paved the way for her comrade
survival a testament to the human Spirit
and the unbreakable bonds forged in the
face of adversity click on one of the
videos on your screen right now